so today big travel day tomorrow big
travel day by land and also by air
probably looking at some delays here
across the west coast that's where all
the action is going to be at we're
talking idaho montana salt lake city all
across the west coast from washington
state all the way down to california so
check your airlines leave early because
this is where we can see the delays and
also up here in wisconsin the up
michigan and the michigan peninsula
otherwise good across the nation for
your travel outlook rain chances not a
big problem tonight we're not going to
see it also tomorrow morning other than
maybe sprinkles and some isolated spots
we get to midday and look at this it
starts to pick up a little more it picks
up more late night tomorrow overnight
into friday morning two and tape run off
a little bit tomorrow in the afternoon
as far as the forecast goes for uh
christmas there you go there's all our
our stockings here's what to expect
we do expect
temperatures to be
57 degrees
some showers
gusty ones at times i love you santa
says brian i always love that little
brian head i have in my wsi computer
look at that head
46 degrees overnight more clouds 63 for
tomorrow mostly cloudy increasing
showers and also increasing wind eight
day forecast there you go wind for the
next few days hang on to your hats
temperatures will chill out chill out
and get cooler for next week in the low
50s that's your most accurate forecast
guys over here